unfortunately on my side of land I
wasn't able to perform when it most
mattered man I can't believe how long
ago this was 2015 is basically the
Middle Ages of eSports
I'm really sorry to all my fans
I mean dyrus had such a long career he
achieved so many things but you can't be
on top forever everything that's there
it's it's been done and now it's time to
open a new book right now my story I'm
screwed
I mean you've gotten kind of old how can
you expect a dinosaur like dyers to keep
up with all these new kids in the top
lane wait he was 23 we've all said it or
seen it online a pro player being
labeled washed-up it's actually an
expression that goes back to the 1920s
used to describe an individual who
literally washed their hands after
completing a job but in time it became a
way of criticizing perceived husband's
in show business sports and later
eSports okay so it depends on the game
but conventional eSports wisdom is that
most players peak in their early 20s and
once they hit 30 they stop being able to
play at the highest level all together
in some games players are even retiring
before the age of 25 I've been playing
the league for a really long time I'm
getting tired I'm not playing
as well as I used to be you play I'm
gonna be announcing my retirement I'm
not gonna be playing in season three and
we're going to be picking up a new AP
carry and that will be announced pretty
shortly now this is a sharp contrast to
traditional sports where players can
reach their peak anywhere from their mid
20s to early 30s and in some sports they
can stay competitive into their 40s take
Vince Carter he's 42 and in January 2020
he's gonna play against the Raptors who
will be wearing a throwback jersey that
Carter himself for in 1999
like he's so old that if you foul him
you're gonna get grounded car privileges
revoked
Giles against the veteran Vince Carter
[Applause]
you respect the rules of our house yeah
while repetitive strain and back
injuries are a factor in most eSports
professional athletes certainly
experienced more physical strain over
the course of their careers so what's
happening here why our players retiring
earlier than their athletic counterparts
even though injuries are less of a
factor I think the biggest challenge
today taking sport as it grows right now
is athlete well-being because we have
this situation where athletes right now
are going from just playing playing
playing playing individually and then
they join a team then you have a player
who is not prepared for the stresses of
an elite athletic career and they can't
really look out for themselves because
often there are 18 19 year old guys and
girls who are just jumping straight from
their living room into a stadium in
eSports there's a ton of pressure to
keep up and that often means long hours
of practice each has a legion of female
fans whom they will never have time to
date because of team this is until 3:00
a.m. ten hours a day seven days I
supposed to be a franchise player and
we're in here talking about practice
elite athletes in traditional sports
practice a lot too of course but there's
a physical limit on the hours you can
put in your body can only take so much
in eSports it's all about what your mind
can handle and people have tried to push
that limit practicing double-digit hours
a day between team streams and ranked
modes there's stereotypes that go along
with the sport of I grind I play hour
upon hour upon hour upon hour I put in
12-hour days and so there's this badge
of honor and eSports that if I grind
more I'm going to get better
I was 10 out straight he's a machine
I know League of Legends and here is the
first problem even with the very best in
organ Amish support staff and wrist
exercises human beings just aren't meant
to sit in front of a screen for sixteen
hours a day
India's under reputation for working
long hours and at 18 years old he's
starting to get injuries more common to
people at least twice his age it's not
healthy but how many organizations are
gonna tell their star player to stop
before they burn out and though these
things are changing a lot of these
players still don't practice in ideal
environments Dmitri I've kept picked up
by lead eSports to play melty blood
leaks eSports yeah sounds very reputable
come on they've got a training facility
and everything I'll send you pictures
hope you enjoy labbing behind a dumpster
oh come on but we understand why they do
it it's because there's a sea of young
players who want to push their way into
the highest tier of competition and take
their spot being on Icarus like getting
into professional gaming my schedule is
basically go to school practice till
like midnight sometimes one and then
Friday night I would drive up live in
the curse house play LCS come home
Sunday night and do the same thing
pretty much a physical and mental toll
of intense practice schedules isn't the
only thing the players have to deal with
they also have to contend with the fact
that fans are constantly bickering about
whether the players are well washed the
miner that steady guru plays on his robe
izuna because of how bad a job like
yours
skadoodle looks dead inside true
statement very dead nothing going on in
here did you guys miss reckless thing at
the relay TC Jesus trash like you know
perhaps nowhere else are the fickle
opinions of fans Illustrated better than
with Pollard when he plays well he's God
ollie
looking for the triple out of the last
man standing with 20 seconds left he has
to touch his they need this round anime
Hideo getting destroyed on this map
picks up a kill now just has to get down
this prophecy but when he messes up he's
bought Ali it's gonna be a stick but not
it's not a stick but didn't look at his
headshot it's a Glock Oh Zeus is another
player who's attracted the ire of
certain commenters but with his victory
at pgl major krakow 2017 he became the
oldest player ever to win a CS major I
just saved all of place than a DeLorean
and second god help me and they wore
measure
and while it's easy enough to say just
ignore it some of the best teams in
eSports are employing a different
strategy hiring staff like sports
psychologists to keep their players
heads in the game instead of on Reddit
players need to have a well being to be
able to perform at their best levels I
for one am shocked when I learn a team
doesn't have a sports and performance
psychologist on staff because in order
to compete at that highest level you
have to be consistent operate as a team
practice hard and have all of that
happen all while avoiding burnout so
physical and mental wellness are clearly
barriers to prolonged player careers but
what else is driving competitors onto
the couch before they can even grow
decent facial hair well meta changes and
game patches are definitely one of them
you know what the meta is right and so
they change everything all the time
whether it's overwatch whether it's
legal legends fortnight for that matter
it's not really an eSport but still when
it's a five person team and the meta
changes every 90 120 days it's like a
whole new game in traditional sports
being a veteran has a certain amount of
value and lets your experience transfer
to younger players developing their
talent faster than they could on their
own
hi I'm Doug Ladd stay away from my
[__] percocets
and do you have any [__] percocets man
alright but in the constantly shifting
sea of meta changes how much has
experience really worth sure some skills
will always be valuable like handling
the pressure of playing under the lights
but how much of a player's career is
relevant at any given moment in time
maybe that's the reason that fighting
games have seen some of the oldest event
winners the fundamentals of fighting
games remain pretty consistent across
not only a games lifespan but even
between games
so when Saco wins a premier event at 39
years old it kind of makes sense all of
his experience with fighting game
fundamentals and knowledge of his
opponents can be instantly translated
into action
[Applause]
don't answer the Cielo
but my little girl
but as a player ages their reflexes
inevitably slow down
it's just a biological reality so if
your play style was all about those snap
reactions adapting into those later
years might prove difficult
now how badly reflexes are affected
depends on the individual but there are
plenty of studies that suggest exercises
of various types can keep your reaction
speed crisp video games have no value
video games teach hand-eye coordination
which is why I now have like reflexes
finally a lot of players have realized
that there are other opportunities out
there after their careers have come to
an end some of which don't involve a
brutal practice schedule whether it's a
transition to coaching commentating or
streaming there are other options for
beloved players that can keep them in
the money and connected to eSports in a
meaningful way now streaming can still
be a grind but at least it's your grind
you set the boundaries plus if you're
one of the best you can make way more
money than your days as a pro player
there reports that you're making more
than a half a million dollars a month I
believe much of that coming from twitch
a lot of the income is definitely coming
from the Amazon and like twitch prime
subscribers we also just hit 5 million
subscribers on YouTube as well and
Instagram just hit over a million
followers and I'm almost there on
Twitter take shroud for example he is no
stranger to competitive success in csgo
but if success is measured in dollars or
in name recognition his streaming career
has been the better move by far whenever
I played you game they're like hey could
you see yourself going pro no absolutely
not
I could never see myself going pro again
in anything Pro in life how about that
and des fran the most popular stage one
player in the overwatch league in terms
of jersey sales retired early opting for
what he called the comfy streamer life
[Music]
coaching and analyst jobs also let
former players pass on their knowledge
and stay connected to the game they love
sometimes that legacy makes things
easier when communicating with their
players I mean my favorite would be
Sonic
he seems very hyped and supporting the
team a lot and he has so much experience
he must be a great coach with so many
barriers to a long career and so many
other options out there it's not
surprising the players go hard and then
burn out early organizational support
that comes with having an increased
staff and carefully managed training can
probably help but it remains to be seen
whether that is the missing piece of the
puzzle players still spend a lot of time
playing and practicing as much as 12
hours a day sometimes but they also live
healthier more balanced lives they're
gonna talk about time management you can
talk about physical fitness you're
talking about eating right yeah hmm sure
don't make hosts like they used to Josh
now that that was a real host remember
twitch emote videos those are some good
times man mean videos these days they
some have the same soul that they used
to okay oh you may not like it this is
what this is pinky gamer physical
performance
all the Eagles or what all the e girls
want to knows what one thing is disgust
and it's